and have many more smell receptors than
other insects like Nathan's and fruit
flies could these order detectors be the
key to if social organization
researchers used CRISPR to knock out a
gene in amps called
orko known to be important for order
detection these are the first transgenic
ants ever made genetically modifying
ants has been tough their eggs for
example the care that is usually only
provided by other amp the regular amps
used in this study are special because
they reproduce parthenogenetic ly making
almost exact copy to themselves which
saves the researchers having to breed
many generations of newton amps when
researchers raised amps without the Orko
genes they were less sensitive to odors
normal ants
hate the smell of permanent marker but
the genetically modified emphasises
seemed to mind based on camera tracking
the mutant ants didn't follow other ants
scent trail and young mutant dance
tended to water instead of joining in
normal nesting behavior these results
suggest that odor it is just important
for foraging and communicating but also
for the very social nature of these ants
live
[Music]
[Music]